este fuego es una anomalía en el
salvador también estas multitudes que el
pasado 16 de septiembre marcharon por
las calles de la capital símbolos
inequívocos de que el descontento con su
gobierno está creciendo entre los
salvadoreños hoy el mensaje para el
gobierno que si uno escucha al pueblo en
este momento este pueblo puede ser capaz
de levantarse y allí bukele intento
criminalizar los que sea que la mayoría
se expresaron de manera pacífica este ex
empresario de apenas 40 años fue elegido
en 2019 con el 53 por ciento de los
votos gracias a un discurso anti
corrupción pero varias de sus decisiones
han levantado la sospecha de una deriva
autoritaria dos medidas alertan
especialmente a la opinión pública
primero la imposición del bitcoin como
moneda de curso legal sabemos que esta
moneda mantiene unas fluctuaciones
drásticas de un segundo a otro cambio de
valor y en las cuales nosotros nos
mantendremos el control sino los grandes
inversionistas que son lo que puede
hacer lavado de dinero además prevé
destituir a un tercio de los jueces y
expulsar a varios fiscales
y vista como un ataque a la
independencia judicial entonces me
parece que es una situación grave si no
hay independencia judicial los derechos
todos los derechos de la ciudadanía no
pueden estar garantizados bukele se
defiende y acusa a la comunidad
internacional de financiar a la
oposición
lamentablemente
son protegidos por algunos amigos de la
comunidad internacional digo algunos
porque no son todos pero si algunos
incluso financiados por que le podría
haber encendido la llama de la
indignación en su país llegó con
promesas de cambios profundos y muchos
empiezan a temer que sean cambios a peor